[Musique]
les courbes du corps les sentiments
amoureux
la sexualité des thématiques abordées à
travers la centaine d'oeuvres exposées à
l'espace grange galerie de temps pierre
un premier événement de ce type dans la
commune l'idée est venue du fait que
j'ai rencontré pas mal d'artistes qui me
disaient qu'ils avaient aucun endroit
pour exposer ce qui était censuré un peu
partout sur les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya un retour au
puritanisme du baiser aux situations
plus audacieuses
huit artistes venus de toute la france
se dévoile sur un espace d'une centaine
de mètres carrés à l'aide du pinceau du
crayon de l'encré de chine
c'est le cas de carreaux 47 ans elle
expose dans cette grange une vingtaine
de frein j'aime bien parler de l'amour
des couples de l'érotisme pas seulement
de là moi aussi à des dessins qui parle
que d'amour et souvent autour de la
femme
ou alors des coups alors je sais pas
pourquoi et les courbes de la femme je
trouve ça joli a défini ou alors les
hommes en complément la masculinité et
la féminité qui s'emboîtent qui se met
en valeur malgré les apparences cette
première exposition de l'année organisée
dans la grange n'a pas pour but de
choquer mais de provoquer la curiosité
du public
tous les voisins sont venus ils ont tous
adoré et je pense qu'ils ont tous fait
des enfants de progresser parle
apparemment les gens sont pas si choqué
que ça peut mal gré mal gré mais plus
d'appréhension publiquement non en fait
j'étais assez étonné la galerie contient
également des peintures plus évocatrices
interdite aux moins de 18 ans pour les
découvrir rendez vous jusqu'au 4 mars
tous les dimanches